[Música]
en primera plana
carlos
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional de france
24 iniciamos nueva temporada del
programa con un asunto central en europa
las consecuencias de la guerra de
ucrania en las casas de los europeos la
crisis energética ya provoca que
hablemos de las previsiones para un duro
invierno con restricciones y planes de
seguridad energética nos acompañan en
este estudio rafael cañas que defenderá
de la delegación de la agencia efe en
francia bienvenido a rafael
muchas gracias carlos buenos días mario
genial sanín profesora de economía
especializada en energías bienvenida a
mario genial muchas gracias y mi
compañero enrique bonet corresponsal del
diario el periódico aquí en francia
bienvenido pérez díaz gracias por la
invitación
europa en medio de la crisis energética
hoy en primera plana
la inflación en la zona euro ha superado
el 9 por ciento los europeos se
enfrentan cada vez precios más caros en
medio de la crisis energética que
afronta el bloque en previsión de un
invierno duro muchos gobiernos ya
preparan los llamados planes de
contingencia europa ya está en alerta
por la interrupción esta misma semana
del suministro del gas ruso a través del
gasoducto nord stream no todos los
socios y cuentan con el mismo nivel de
dependencia que ahora se intenta reducir
al máximo del gas ruso aquí en francia y
hemos visto esta misma semana la primera
ministra lisa depor pidiendo a las
empresas que diseñen sus planes de
sobriedad energética una cuestión que
también pudiera afectando a los hogares
tras un verano en el que hemos hablado
de eventuales razonamientos de cambios
de hábitos e incluso de palabras gruesas
como el anuncio de manuel macro de que
se acabaron los tiempos de abundancia
repasemos algunas portadas diario 'el
país' la crisis de la energía fuerza a
la unión europea' activar medidas de
emergencia y compare esta crisis con la
del euro o la de la pandemia en esta
senda el diario 'cinco días' euro para
reformar a su mercado eléctrico ante la
espiral de precios
sobriedad francia a los pies del muro
dice el rotativo que el gobierno francés
evoca por primera vez un eventual
racionamiento the economist se pregunta
en esta portada si las sanciones hasta
ahora aprobadas contra moscú están
funcionando bueno mucho se han comentado
para empezar en estos últimos días las
palabras de macro vamos a escucharlo
estamos viviendo un gran cambio el fin
de la abundancia rafael a qué se refiere
el presidente y 15 aquí intenta preparar
que intenta prepararnos no estamos lo
suficientemente aliados en europa para
las consecuencias de la guerra yo creo
que sí que en europa nos están no
estamos suficientes concienciados a
nivel general de la población y sobre
todo yo creo que intenta preparar
a la población que las empresas intentan
concienciar las de
de que es necesario recortar el consumo
energético por las buenas antes de que
por las malas haya recortes forzados el
fin de la abundancia mayo genial para mí
es interesante porque siendo economista
cuando algo es abundante el precio es
bajo o cero o negativo entonces es
importante entonces ya para empezar el
nombre la abundancia el nombre que le
puso el presidente es a francés y si
entonces en realidad la energía no es
abundante nunca lo ha sido es un recurso
escaso lo que yo creo que está marcando
con esa con esa con esa interlocución es
justamente que tenemos que cambiar la
forma en la que nosotros consideramos
esta energía que la que tratamos como
abundante y de ahora más vamos a tener
que tener una
una especial atención en cómo consumimos
esa energía y probablemente van a ver
reformas ligadas al mercado eléctrico a
los mercados a la tarificación que van a
reflejar esta este nuevo paradigma enric
como lo interpreta esa frase sí yo creo
que es una frase de razón algo que había
sido dicho desde hacía tiempo por la
ecología política por el sectores del
marxismo que era la contradicción entre
un modelo económico el capitalismo que
defiende un crecimiento infinito en un
mundo de recursos finitos y sobre dos
recursos cimientos a nivel de las
energías de carbono de las energías
fósiles
que puede sorprender que estas
declaraciones como de macro no y yo
luego también lo que creo que es
interesante de esta frase es grande
contextualizar la porque es verdad que
el presidente francés ha hecho
declaraciones de este tipo a lo largo
del verano nos hizo el 14 de julio y
también a mediados de agosto habló de
que ese que en europa porque los
franceses deben de aceptar pagar el
precio de su libertad y son
declaraciones del fondo de anunciando
sangre sudor y lágrimas que en parte
vienen a poco a intentar influir la la
opinión pública en un momento de que es
proclive a que haya protestas no sólo
por la
malestar que puede provocar la subida
energética se está curando en salud sino
también por afuera exacto puede meter
miembro de malestar que puede provocar
la inflación una inflación elevada en
humo sin sin aumentos salariales que por
otro lado es lo que pretende putting con
todo esto es decir que hay un estallido
social en europa que hay un caldo de
cultivo con la inflación con los precios
rafael es es evidente que putin desde
hace años a través de diversas acciones
y diversas políticas ha intentado
dividir europa la unión europea ha
intentado sembrar cizaña en países
europeos a nivel fuera de la energía lo
hemos estado viendo en las últimas
semanas una vez que se convocan las
elecciones legislativas adelantadas en
italia empieza a ver una oleada de
de inmigrantes y refugiados por el
mediterráneo' que salen del este de
libia la zona que controlan sus aliados
y los mercenarios de wagner en dirección
a italia para
a ayudar a las perspectivas de sus
aliados de la extrema derecha italiana a
nivel de la energía está haciendo lo
mismo con
cortes técnicos
supuestamente técnicos puede que si no
lo sabemos de los envíos de gas por
north stream con amenazas de cortes o
cortes a las empresas que no les pagan
en rublos el resultado es aumentar la
inflación perdón aumenta el precio de la
energía
[Música]
el aumento del precio de la energía se
extiende a hace que suban los precios de
todo y aumentar la inflación si ves en
él
los cuadros de inflación lo que hace que
aumente todo prácticamente todo es el
brutal aumento del precio de la energía
de los últimos meses y por ello la
palabra de moda son los planes de
contingencia con un doble objetivo
aumentar las reservas de cara al
invierno interno lógicamente aquí en el
hemisferio norte y evitar que el choque
entre una demanda alta y unas reservas
bajas disparen el precio para el
consumidor
marujina cómo se están diseñando estos
planes verdad que estamos viendo medidas
vamos conociendo medidas casi cada día
en un país europeo ayer mismo italia que
mantenía el tope de las calefacciones a
19 grados
españa con el alumbrado vamos cada día
vamos conociendo nuevas nuevas medidas
cómo se diseña un buen plan de
contingencia that con este doble
objetivo
la pregunta es muy interesante y la
respuesta en alguna medida se encuentra
en distintos países de latinoamérica que
tienen experiencia en la gestión de
crisis energética que europa bien área
en este sentido en mirar a países que
tienen la experiencia como américa en
américa latina no sí absolutamente de
hecho yo tengo estudiantes que han
estudiado por ejemplo al mercado
brasilero en distintos países de
latinoamérica hay precios que dependen
del recurso por ejemplo hay países que
tienen mucha hidro tienen un precio que
depende del régimen hídrico si hay mucha
agua poca agua hay países este es el
caso por ejemplo de brasil también en el
caso de méxico que tiene precios zonales
dependiendo de lugares donde hay un
diferencial hay mucho calor o mucho frío
y entonces el diferencial de calefacción
o de refrigeración es importante y la
demanda por el sistema pues está la
intención entonces hay un tema de
prising de cómo ponemos los precios y
después hay un tema de cuando él prising
no funciona y este es un tema importante
en europa estamos comenzando
directamente por las restricciones sin
pasar por el pricing sin pasar por ver
cómo podemos tener precios más
inteligentes porque tenemos mediadores
inteligentes tenemos una serie de
infraestructuras que nos permitirían
tener un prising más inteligente e
incitar a las empresas y a los
particulares a tener un consumo más
razonable más sobrio
entonces latinoamérica además de tener
experiencia en eso a pesar de no tener
tanta infraestructura para poder ver
cuál es la mejor hora el mejor horario
para poner un precio diferenciado
también tiene experiencia en gestión en
términos de crisis en mi infancia en
uruguay nosotros teníamos cortes
programados en determinada hora de
determinado día de la semana que ya
sabíamos cuál iba a ser teníamos un
corte programado durante dos horas nada
dramático y uno lo que hacía era
desplazar la comida
a la zona más fría del refrigerador y
prepararse con
un juego de cartas en europa podemos
incluso cargar los ordenadores o sea nos
podemos preparar durante esas dos horas
no es nada grave vamos a sobrevivir
claro es que la consecuencia de la
guerra de ucrania en las casas de los
europeos es impresionante porque hablar
para un europeo por ejemplo de nuestra
generación de un corte de suministro de
racionamiento esto es un choque brutal
para la mentalidad europea como decía
marx eugenia en latinoamérica están
acostumbrados pero para nosotros esto no
lo hemos vivido sí es verdad es un
choque muy importante aunque luego y es
verdad que hay que contextualizarlo
también el sentido de que de que ha
habido la pandemia del cobit
19 vimos cosas completamente
inimaginable
quizás aún más imagino imaginable que el
hecho de quedarse sin luz un gran de
obras obras y la agenda se aceptó que
estoy yo creo que también es lo que
puede final hacer que la gente si hay
medidas de seguridad energética al final
se terminen aceptando como hemos visto
incluso este verano no en españa que a
diferencia de francia ha
empezado a adoptar medidas como limitar
el aire acondicionado en oficinas
público en edificios de la
administración y ahí la gente lo ha
aceptado yo creo que la experiencia del
cobi 19 puede contribuir a que se
acepten medidas situaciones que eran
severas para las generaciones de las
nuevas generaciones eran completamente
inimaginable transformando ese mismo
ejemplo de la pandemia rafa la pregunta
es la pedagogía para la sobriedad
energética va a ser suficiente como era
como no fue suficiente la pedagogía para
ponerse la mascarilla sino que llegó un
punto en el que había que obligar
volvemos a tener casi el mismo debate la
pedagogía esta vez va a ser suficiente o
no
yo creo que puede ser suficiente para
una buena parte de la población siempre
habrá una minoría que diga piense a mí
nadie me dice que es lo que tengo que
hacer y cuánto tengo que consumir y si
me lo tengo para asumir
esto restringe mi libertad creo que
también puede influir mucho a nivel del
ciudadano medio
el que perciba que o si la sobriedad
está repartida y extendida por toda la
sociedad o sólo se aplica a
los más débiles ya los sobre los que es
más fácil imponer la sí si un ciudadano
ve que las luces de su ciudad de los
monumentos las grandes empresas
no se apagan no se moderan llega a una
empresa oa una oficina gubernamental y
hay una calefacción o un aire
acondicionado
puesto de forma excesiva y la voy a
pasar frío yo en mi casa este invierno
va a depender mucho de esos y vamos a
seguir analizando toda esta situación
toda esta crisis energética que vive
europa va a ser a la vuelta de pausa que
en primera plana hasta ahora
en france 24 siga las entrevistas
exclusivas con las personalidades más
influyentes del mundo
jagger joss web pro cycling outside en
encuentros con grandes líderes políticos
[Música]
actores artistas deportistas y
científicos gracias a
grandes personalidades y sus ideas están
en la entrevista de france 24 y france
24 puntocom liberté égalité actual y te
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de la crisis energética que
afronta europa lo hacemos con los
periodistas rafael calles y enric bonet
y mario gene sanín profesora de economía
especializada en energías
mario genial antes de irnos a la pausa
estábamos hablando con rafael de la
pedagogía de si va a ser suficiente o si
se va a tener que llegar a algo más si
hubiese cortes pero para un europeo
preguntar esto si hubiese cortes cómo se
podrían estructurar cuál sería el
panorama
se adquirían estos estos cortes de
racionamientos porque es una situación
completamente inédita para un europeo si
en realidad hay dos cosas la primera es
que no hay que olvidar que actualmente
la mayor parte de dos de los países
tenemos precios regulados y en
particular en francia el consumidor no
ve el precio real y todos ningún
consumidor el rico como el pobre no ven
el precio real y entonces eso no incita
a reducir el consumo cuando es necesario
o sea que lo primero la primera
pedagogía es la conciencia que la gente
sepa por lo que se está pagando la
primera cosa que nosotros deberíamos
hacer dado que tenemos medidores
inteligentes es señalar y se ha hecho en
algunas regiones en bretaña ya en la
gente ha recibido
sms diciendo atención el sistema está en
tensión puede usted reducir su consumo
en vez de hacer solamente eso en
realidad lo que tendremos que hacer es
el sistema está en tensión
estos son los precios o sea tendríamos
que tener un sistema lo que se llaman
precios inteligentes que lo podemos
hacer porque en europa tenemos la
infraestructura con los medios
inteligentes para eso lo pusimos
justamente entonces podemos modular el
consumo y si a mí me dicen en este
horario usted va a pagar el doble el
megavatio/hora que si usted espera dos
horas para poner su lavadora de vida
evidentemente yo lo voy a hacer entonces
la primera cosa es
incitar lo más posible a los
consumidores a tener darles planes
ofertas de precios inteligentes para
reducir el consumo en el pico y pasar el
consumo del pico al valle porque es en
el pico que usamos gas en el resto en
por ejemplo en españa usamos renovables
en francia podemos usar nuclear si están
prendidas es el primer punto traducido
al lenguaje común es poner la lavadora a
las tres de la mañana traducir luego
como una explanada de las 3 de la mañana
y que eso me sea rentable que haya una
diferencia porque si a mí me pagan lo
mismo me cobra lo mismo por hasta las 3
de la mañana que al lado de la tarde
bien pues la pregunta es esto va a ser
suficiente si está bien establecida esta
estrategia entendemos que sí que lo
sería si hay una política de precios eso
depende del país en algunos países como
su generación de base de todas maneras
es gas como es el caso de alemania no no
y entonces es la cuestión es hay una
probabilidad
no nula de que nos corten de tener
cortes según como sea la regulación la
probabilidad aumenta y entonces en
particular si seguimos como estábamos en
el 'business as usual' vamos a tener
cortes pero la segunda cosa es es
dramático no no es dramático porque los
cortes son programados uno lo sabe si yo
vivo en el décimo piso de un apartamento
tengo el tiempo de subir mis diez pisos
porque yo sé a qué hora me van a cortar
y esa hora y esa cantidad de tiempo está
programada es organizarse es organizarse
enric la pedagogía va a ser suficiente o
vamos a tener que llegar a un estadio
superior
lo veremos yo creo que es lo más claves
que haya terminado hablando de políticas
públicas no debe ser como lo que se ha
hecho en españa y aquí en francia que
nos ha hecho
las empresas que cada empresa desarrolló
su plan si las empresas contribuyen
puede ser un espacio también de
pedagogía para ciudadanos de ver los
gestos y
los buenos gestos se normalizan no pues
después puede contribuir a ahorros
energéticos importantes tanto a nivel de
consumo de energía en sentando en
empresas como en domicilios pero también
a nivel de próximo respecto a la fusión
del teletrabajo que se había
desarrollado mucho durante la pandemia
del cob y que ahora parecía un poco que
se estaba desapareciendo
puede volver se puede normalizar como
algo que puede quedar y puede ser muy
eficaz también a nivel de conducción o
lo que se llaman los gestos ecológicos
se conduciendo es también es algo que
son son géneros que pueden ser muy muy
efectivos que es verdad que el precio
puede contribuir luego yo creo que
también es importante que se protejan a
ciudadanos a
las clases trabajadoras del impacto de
sus precios que es en persona en francia
ha sido positivo que se hayan bloqueado
los precios y que tenga esa percepción
de continuidad no que antes decía decía
rafa vemos que es un rompecabezas
diferentes diferentes perspectivas otras
europa que parece que ahora sí reacciona
la necesidad de reformar el mercado
energético hay una reunión de los
ministros de energía el día de 19 de
septiembre tal y como pedían socios como
españa con el gas dominando el precio
del mercado de la electricidad y con
estos precios exorbitantes la necesidad
de desacoplar lo que digamos lo que lo
que se ha venido buscando con la llamada
excepción ibérica rafael o enric
bruselas ha reaccionado tarde a la
evidencia una vez más yo creo porque si
es evidente que el sistema de fijación
de precios de la electricidad es muy
complejo hay muchos actores implicados
y yo creo que sin ningún tipo de mala fe
no querían modificarlo a la ligera
porque idear un sistema alternativo es
muy complejo pero españa ya empezó a
levantar la voz de alarma en octubre
pasado cuando mucho antes de la guerra
los precios del gas se habían disparado
y contaminaban se expandían y afectaban
a todo el resto de precios de
electricidad
y españa- aliada con portugal no
consiguieron visto que bruselas no
reaccionaba decidieron ir por su lado y
consiguieron después de negociaciones
complicadas
aplicar su propio sistema
en junio ha empezado y se ha revelado
bastante eficaz el precio de la
electricidad ha seguido subiendo pero
mucho menos que en países como alemania
y francia- dónde está realmente al doble
me gustaría apuntar desde que la
comisión europea anunció la intervención
en el proyecto de intervención de
emergencia en el mercado del lunes
alemania el precio mayorista de la
electricidad cayó casi la mitad en dos
días y el precio del mercado de
referencia del gas en europa que está en
amsterdam
bajó un 21% entre el miércoles y hoy
viernes es que no sé si a veces estamos
siendo muy pesimistas pero luego hay
otras hay otros indicadores que bueno
también alemania con dos ha puesto las
pilas y ha querido rellenar esas
reservas
lo ha hecho muy rápidamente en los
últimos días no
estamos siendo demasiadas trophies estás
poner el cursor en el el pesimismo en el
catastrofismo en esta crisis no se sabe
muy bien yo creo que es muy importante
lo que decíamos porque
cuando los mercados observan una línea
directriz
los mercados reaccionan y la la la
en la última declaración de vanderlei en
efectivamente es aparentemente por lo
que vemos en los mercados más creíbles
si se acuerdan antes de versalles ya
había hablado de reformar el mercado del
gas y de poner un precio un precio
máximo pero es verdad que esta semana
cuando lo dijo ya fue bastante más claro
y en aquel en aquel momento los mercados
no habían reaccionado si en el consejo
de seguridad francés que van a hablar
sobre la energía hay unas líneas
directivas claras donde hay una política
para lo que llamamos esto de desplazar
la demanda del pico al valle
inmediatamente los mercados van a
reaccionar y esto que estamos viendo de
los precios que por los por los cielos
van a disminuir entonces es muy
importante la credibilidad no es no es
tanto un escenario catastrofista sino
ponernos en una línea directa directriz
muy claro y luego a eugenia como
profesora de economía la receta está o
no pueden ser las mismas tampoco en una
situación de inflación en eeuu como en
europa no puede hacer lo mismo el pueblo
europeo que la fed a aumentar los tipos
de interés no puede ser lo mismo porque
el componente de la crisis de la subida
de precios no es igual aquí en europa es
más exógeno digamos más llegado la
energía y es más endógeno en eeuu no
puede ser igual porque el impacto además
que tiene en la población es
completamente distinto el impacto que
tiene en el tramado industrial es
distinto de hecho el problema que
tenemos en europa es que tenemos la
misma política monetaria para países que
tienen distinta estructura económica
entonces actualmente alemania por
ejemplo si se hubieron de
divorciar amos los precios de la energía
en los distintos países alemania
perdería muchísima competitividad en
relación a francia que tiene nuclear por
ejemplo entonces no es para nada lo
mismo y no es para lo mismo como impacta
el mercado de trabajo y el consumidor y
como diciendo brevemente ya para que si
el banco centro europeo sube los tipos
de interés digamos que lo que se pone ya
un poco entre lejos y es la recuperación
tras la pandemia que va a ser un
espejismo no la recuperación económica
eso es un poco el escenario que
afrontamos
por eso como decíamos aquí es muy
importante tener en cuenta que si no
tenemos políticas claras ya mismo y por
eso es que yo creo que no estamos en
contacto sismo es realmente realista
ponerse es sentarse sobre la mesa y
idear políticas claras que protejan a
los consumidores más vulnerables y a los
trabajadores que necesitan la energía
para poder seguir trabajando
por ejemplo a los taxistas
hay mucha mucha gente mucha actividad
liberal que depende del precio de la
energía vamos a tener protestas
importantes con lo que empezamos el
programa por cierto que no hay mal que
por bien no venga' dice el refrán y lo
cierto es que los ecologistas ven en
esta crisis la oportunidad de hablar de
sobriedad de fuentes limpias ucrania es
un poco el detonante de todo esto no si
a nivel a nivel ideológico es un
contexto muy muy proclive abraham para
que el ecologismo político avance no y
ya lo fue la comida en cierta forma
ahora más estamos encadenando crisis
donde el trasfondo al final es la
colocar avanzar
el contexto es ideal pero es cierto que
están habiendo muchas contradicciones
contradicciones por ejemplo con alemania
volviendo a abrir centrales de carbón y
no solo alemanes sino también otros
países europeos incluso contradicciones
a nivel ecológico con con con españa con
un gobierno de izquierdas que se siente
impune está impulsando y se ha
convertido en una cuestión de estado el
gasoducto entre entre entre españa
francia y para llevar al gas a alemania
que es una infraestructura que a nivel
ecológico pues es muy criticable no
estoy estoy de acuerdo que a nivel para
avanzar en el debate público
el contexto es ideal pero que al mismo
tiempo están habiendo muchas
contradicciones en esta cuestión y que
está relacionado con la cuestión de la
unió europea yo creo que es interesante
elevar el nivel del debate estratégico
en el fondo europa está pecando en este
en esa situación de que no hay una
estrategia conjunta a nivel energético
plazo que la llama no sea a corto plazo
eso no está en política por eso muchos
acorazados y cada país mira para para sí
mismo muchos ecologistas dicen estos
días y esto ya lo avanzamos hace 20 años
el problema es que era muy fácil con el
gas barato seguirá avanzando sin
reformar nada
sí
he sido corresponsal en bruselas 12 años
y realmente
las redes transeuropeas de transporte y
de energía
se llevan debatiendo desde principios de
los años 90 y en el caso de la energía
está muy muy atrasada respecto a los
planes iniciales
en concreto el que más nos afecta a
nosotros
españa y portugal la península ibérica
son son una isla con muy poca conexión
especialmente en gas porque francia se
opone por motivos nacionales si hay
conexión eléctrica que a francia le
conviene por porque así puede exportar o
importar electricidad en función de cómo
va su producción nuclear me tengo que ir
ya a rafa muchísimas gracias a los tres
ha sido un placer tenerles en este
primer prometen por a de todos ustedes
hasta la próxima semana en primera plana
gracias
no no